welcome to weird wiki while other
youtubers recycle old reddit content
yours truly we're doing something
innovative so it's time to hop on this
train before it leaves the station here
we're gonna gonna get right into this
boys reminding you that any time you
think the human race is normal or boring
you can just refer to these weird videos
from now on to start we have the
world-famous Bushman I didn't know
Bushmen were a thing and no I'm not
talking about tribe I'm talking about
David Johnson who is a busker and the
way he asks for money is by scaring them
with a plant yes that's right apparently
people can't see through like two leaves
and they get scared which to which I
thought well you definitely wouldn't
give this person money until in the wiki
article it says that he actually on a
good year is making $60,000 a year
scaring people with a bush in front of
his face what am i doing on YouTube this
guy is crushing it and that's probably
tax-free income that's cash baby so the
world famous Bushmen if you see him on
the street don't look down on them he's
probably richer than you are next
article we have the 52 Hertz whale aka
the loneliest whale in the world it's
the sound that only one whale in the
world makes happens every year we pick
it up on hydrophones which is apparently
a way to listen underwater here's what
that sounds like
[Music]
no I'm just kidding this is actually
what it sounds like that is the sound of
deep that is the sound of a whale who
knows what loneliness is and this whale
has become somewhat famous on our
mammalian world we've created
feature-length documentaries about this
whale and apparently BTS
the k-pop group also used them in a song
called whale e'en 52 which is supposed
to be a metaphor for the loneliness of
adolescence which could not be more of
an adolescent idea that you're a 1 of 1
when surrounded by a bunch of other
people listening to the exact same song
feeling the exact same way yeah
brings brings me back all right well I'm
bored next Wiki cosmic latte guys have
you ever wondered yourself what do nerds
do when they're not busy solving the
great questions of life and the answer
to that question is solving the most
useless questions in life given enough
time all scientists without Direction
eventually head towards what I call you
add meaning useless answers to dumb
questions such as what is the average
color of our universe a completely
pointless question that will get us
nowhere but we spent a lot of time
trying to find out but eventually they
came to the right answer the cosmic
latte and it took a while to name that
color because they took a poll and
cosmic latte was definitely the best
among the names up for debate among them
were primordial clam chowder cosmic
creep back that's a bad one cosmic cream
big bang buff and cosmic latte actually
got some of the least number of votes
but they ended up voting it in anyway
because it was the only one that sounded
sensible and I like the name so much
that I think I'm gonna name my third
Channel that when I started or my new
future band named the cosmic latte I
liked it so guys now you're leaving with
completely useless knowledge I hope you
use it for the next time you're on the
street you won't be scared by this man
[Music]